this is the Jocko underground podcast
I'm sitting here with Echo Charles once
again seemed to be sitting with you on a
fairly regular basis which can be a
little bit annoying but it's all good
challenging yeah sure I understand so I
was I was
look every day for me I'm thinking
through things and one thing I was
thinking about the other day I got got
into some situations started handling
some things and I realized how much I
relied and how much I see good leaders
rely
on being balanced on not
getting themselves into extreme
situations or into attitudes where
they're handling things in an extreme
manner
now this is obviously nothing new
in fact it's so nothing new that when I
was on Tim ferriss's podcast the first
time which I had never been interviewed
before
and he asked me what makes a good leader
and I said number one humility
I said number two someone that is
balanced
so
again in the past like week I've been in
some scenarios either with clients and
seen how they're handling things or
myself and having to get through some
situations
and it's
I realize that I'm not getting tripped
up like a good thing I'm being
complementary to myself same thing I'm
being compromised to my other leaders
that I work with
they don't get tripped up they don't get
sucked into problems and that is because
they are balanced so
it's fresh in my mind because I I I
would say it's not something that I'm
haven't been reminding people about
enough that's what I'm feeling I haven't
been reminding people enough about
listen being balanced is
is usually the best way to handle things
right it's usually the best way to
handle things for some reason human
beings have a tendency to not do that
yeah for some reason human beings have a
tendency to pick a direction and go one
thousand percent in that direction in
fact I had a name for this
when I was in the SEAL Teams and I was
putting guys through some training and I
would give them an adjustment I'd be
like hey you need to do a little bit
more of this guess what they would do
nine million percent in that direction
and I would call it or I'd say hey you
need to be a little less aggressive or a
little more aggressive and then I and
then they would do another iteration and
they would go so hard the opposite way
and I say hey you guys just did this is
the term I'd say classic team guy over
correction meaning you say hey be you
know you got to be a little more
aggressive they go out there and just
get nuts or you say hey you need to
check yourself then they don't move you
would see this all the time
so so why am I talking about this when
you get in when you get confronted
and that's a strong word but when you
get confronted with a new idea or an
opposing idea we as human beings have a
tendency to have an extreme reaction to
this new idea an extreme reaction to
this opposing idea
and it's not good
it's not good
it's not good to get emotional it's not
good to take the extreme opposite stance
we're doing this all the time by the way
in America right now you know you have
an opinion I have opinion
I maybe don't agree with all of your
opinions so I take the hardest possible
stance against your opinion and I fully
dig in on my opinion it causes problems
so
when somebody does present you with a
new idea or an opposing idea
instead of taking to check yourself
and a good way to check yourself is be
humble on other ways like okay what is
it that I like about Echo Charles's ID
he's presenting an idea I've not really
heard it before or it's different it's
very different from what I want to do
instead of thinking how can I
immediately smash his idea over the head
with a baseball bat I think what part of
the have what part of echo's ideas are
good well part of his you know it's kind
of different than mine okay what part of
it can I agree with where can I accept
some of his ideas when I go on the
attack to you if I say well actually
your idea is not going to work because
of this you are going to
my attack is going to cause your
defenses to go up it's going to cause
you to get more aggressive and hostile
with your idea and it's going to
separate us from being able to come to
some kind of a conclusion
can be come to some kind of a resolution
I shouldn't say conclusion for you and I
be able to agree on something
and it stems from the fact that I am not
thinking in a balanced way so
what are the good attributes for a
leader or human being to have
be humble yes absolutely and being
humble will allow you hopefully to find
some balance in your interactions with
other people and find balance inside
your own brain housing group
um so my wife used to like help her her
friends found you know how like okay you
know some people they they're so into
helping other people or taking care of
things for other people like oh if if
you're going to I don't know you're
gonna go on a trip or something
she'll jump in with all the hotel
recommendations she'll even be like hey
I'll call yeah yeah this is how she used
to be right
um
and she'll be like I'll even call the
hotel I know a guy there or something
and then she'll like go out of her way
to do a bunch of stuff so what would
what would start happening is
it became she basically takes all on her
own takes on a task for someone else a
bunch of tests and then those tasks
slowly slowly become stressful and then
she's like in this stressful mode starts
getting mad and then on top of it later
on the person like not only did they not
ask for the help it's like they come off
as less appreciative than by her
standard you know yeah she runs that
risk and she's got a grudge I'm guessing
this guy don't mean to throw anything on
yeah on Sarah Charles but like I'm
thinking that maybe with that whole
scenario that you just talked about like
when you do something to help something
somebody and it turns out to be a much
bigger task if I'm like hey Echo can you
come and I remember we
um
we used to train with this guy as a
black belt Greg no Craig Craig freaking
old school black belt from Fabio Santos
and he was an arborist do you know what
that is something having to do with
trees yeah so he used to do tree stuff
and one day he I go hey bro like I got
this tree in my yard can you come help
me get it out and he's like he's like
how big is it you know I like held up my
hands I don't know like maybe like three
inches around or whatever maybe maybe
four or five inches around right and he
goes yeah yeah cool you know let me know
when to come by so I sent him a text or
whatever we did back then called him he
comes by and like the tree was way
bigger and way more and whatever kind of
like root system it had as soon as he
saw it I saw a look in his face and he
was you know he's gonna do a bro deal
right yeah yeah and he did a bro deal
for me but I could see that it hurt you
know and both of us were out there with
pickaxes at the end you know freaking
digging the root system out it was a
serious day's labor he thought he was
going to come over with a chainsaw you
know cut it down whatever pop pop you
know rip some Roots out be gone in 20
minutes he's there for four hours I like
he was Sarah Charles at that point yeah
and he I mean he's a freaking awesome
guy so there was no no Factor but that
can build so yeah so so how does this
tie into balance Okay so
talk about the over correction
essentially so so what you do is uh or
what so what would happen with her is it
that it wasn't an incident it was how
she was that's how she is and there's I
know a lot of people like that where
they like
sometimes they insert themselves too
much into your thing you know
and they mean well but it's just it's
part of their personality but there's so
much expression that expression is
stings doesn't it a little bit means
well oh that one stings but yeah but
doing that to that degree anyway will
like there's some drawbacks for the
other person and yourself for everybody
so you shouldn't do that to like that
much of a degree right
um nonetheless should we do that from
time to time like pretty often too so it
got to the point where like I see it
happening the whole time I'm like
there's it's a lose situation where
you're gonna help you're gonna be
stressful for doing it for taking on the
responsibility and then they're not
going to be appreciative in your mind
because not only do they not know they
didn't ask for it and then you're gonna
be mad at them now something you did you
know so every once in a while I gotta
kind of break it to her a little bit you
know but every time I would she'd be
like fine I just won't help anybody yeah
I'm like what that's your classic team
guy over Corrections yeah no although
that's like a conscious sort of emotion
the classic teen guy over correction is
might be a little bit of that but it's
also oh I'm too far right go hard left
or too far left go hard right that's
that's what we need to watch out for and
you know this is one of those things
where you know you were talking to me
about
you're like you get to see me in a lot
of different situations where I'm
interacting with people and you get to
see me sometimes where people are kind
of bringing it or coming at me or
whatever
and you know just through Echelon front
you see me doing interviews you see me
get interviews you you you you
um
you go through tons and tons of video of
me doing whatever and and you know you
were talking about like it's
seeing me get flustered or seeing me get
trapped or seeing me get uh uh you know
got see me get got yeah and you you were
saying like hey you know I don't really
see a lot of you getting emotional I
don't see a lot of you getting got I
don't see a lot of you getting caught
and and flustered when something's
happening
and part of that reason
is because it's because of this idea
that we're talking about being balanced
so when someone says something that's
meant to
off balance me
I know that it's going to be very easy
if I feel off balance it's very easy for
me to over correct in the other
direction and so this is the this is
really the meat of what I wanted to
bring up today is that point that
when someone comes at you
and you over correct it doesn't help
solve the problem and it doesn't make
you
come across
in a good way
it doesn't it doesn't help you solve the
problem it doesn't come across in a good
way
and so it's a problem
so when you get pushed off balance which
is going to happen somebody's going to
ask a question you're going to say
something to you somebody's going to put
you on the spot
it's real easy to over correct so
instead of over correcting
just take a step just just regain your
balance a little bit and put yourself
right back in the middle they pushed you
off to the right come right don't go far
left just go to the back to the middle
you don't need to by the way I don't I
might think if Echo comes at me
with
I don't even like your plan
it may seem like in order to achieve
balance that what I need to do you
pushed me off to the right I need to
push you back to the left in order to
maintain my balance but it's not true if
you say I don't even like I don't like
your plan if you say that to me and I
say you couldn't come up with a better
plan in a million years that's now it
should be like you said something
negative I'm saying something negative
now we're balanced but it's not true
it's not true what I should do when you
push me off balance of I don't like your
plan what I should do is I should say
oh you got some feedback what is it that
you don't like about it and I'm right
there I'm right in the middle I'm right
where I should be and you know who's off
balance now
you you're now off balance and but
you don't have to push me back you
realize that you're off bound so you try
and Center yourself up and that's how we
can reach a resolution
so keep that in mind this is a very
important thing that will help you in so
many aspects of your life when you get
pushed off balance don't over correct go
back to Center
center
with that what we've got some q a
activities yes sir first question Jaco
I'm on the path
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen
go to Jocko underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us
strengthen this Legion of Troopers that
are in the game with us so thank you
it's Jocko underground.com it costs
eight dollars and 18 cents a month and
if you can't afford to support us we can
still support you just email assistance
Jocko underground.com and we'll get you
taken care of until then we will see you
mobilized
Underground